canada's freedom
convoy is picking up steam and crossing
borders with new protests brewing in
europe and the us now needless to say
joe biden's not particularly happy after
fully endorsing the samurai it's a 2020
that left oh dozens dead
caused billions in damage property
damage arson and looting and thousands
of cops injured now all of a sudden
biden he's now urging the canadian prime
minister the gutless cowardly trudeau to
squash the peaceful freedom convoy in
ottawa apparently by any means necessary
in a call biden and trudeau agreed that
these truckers at the border pose a
serious problem and the canadian prime
minister promised quote quick action on
enforcing the law keep in mind this is
the same joe biden that not only refuses
to secure our southern border because
it's now chaos he has been aiding and
abetting the entire law breaking going
on in our southern border illegal
immigrants also are given preferential
treatment unlike anyone else that
travels across the northern border down
south yep illegal immigrants there's no
need to be covert tested there's no
vaccine mandate there's nothing
whatsoever just free travel and airfare
to the state of your choice in the
middle of the night two three four am or
as jinsaki calls them early morning
flights anyway we pay for all of this
who's going to pay for the food housing
health care education that would be you
the american people but joe has a very
different opinion on the northern border
because right on cue instead of meeting
with truckers working out a solution
following the science the cowardly prime
minister justin trudeau along with
government officials in ontario they're
now threatening
these peaceful protesters you know the
guys that were the heroes of the
pandemic with a massive 100 thousand
dollar fine
one year prison time they want to seize
their trucks and their licenses and
pretty much destroy their lives now some
are even calling for canada's military
to intervene and forcefully remove the
truckers michigan's pro-lockdown
governor
whitmer the witless one even reportedly
offered a heavy equipment across the
border to help remove the trucks and by
the way to the trucker's credit they see
the problem and they have opened up one
lane so commerce can continue they're
trying to work with and take care of the
people that they usually are working to
feed and help every day
listen to what the ontario premier doug
ford had to say earlier today take a
listen
we're now two weeks into the siege of
the city of ottawa
i call it a siege because that's what it
is
it's an illegal occupation
this is no longer a protest
so let me be as clear as i can
there will be consequences for these
actions
and they will
be severe today i'm using my authority
as premier of ontario to declare a state
of emergency in our province
fines for non-compliance will be severe
with a maximum penalty of one hundred
000
and up to a year imprisonment
really you're going to start a fight
with the truckers you're going to send
in the military you're going to take
away their livelihood now a court in
canada canada is also attempting to
freeze over 8 million dollars in
donations to the freedom convoy but the
christian u.s based crowd funding site
uh hosting the donations gives send go
they don't take orders from canada and
they are vowing to get those funds to
the truckers one way or another and keep
in mind despite attempts by trudeau and
other leftists they've been lying and
vilifying these truckers and calling
them racist and every other name they
can think of all this is you know
basically the convoy has been comprised
of peaceful canadians from many
different races backgrounds religions
who all share one simple message no more
mandates no more lockdowns no more covet
19 restrictions they want life to return
to normal for every man woman and child
that's it and by the way let's say that
trudeau gets his way and he sends in the
vaccination police and every trucker is
vaccinated and every trucker gets a
booster guess what they can still get
contract covert 19 they can still
transmit covert 19.
the mandates in that sense are pointless
if you're fully vaccinated vaccinated
and boosted even have natural immunity
you can get covert 19. that's canada and
the us not following the science as they
like to lecture us so now there are
pretty much two options on the table for
canada's government with of course the
advice of tough joe biden who doesn't
lift a finger
to secure our southern border
let the truckers make their own health
decisions leave them alone and recognize
that even fully vaccinated people with
boosters can transmit covert or send in
the troops and
arrest the truckers it's a peaceful
protest you know what's going to happen
all hell will break loose that will be
the government starting a fight people
may die
uh they're gonna what take the rigs
their livelihoods away from them they're
gonna find them a hundred thousand
dollars each they're gonna put them in
jail for a year
to me the answer is obvious restore
freedom leave the heroes of the pandemic
alone
and our own investigative reporter sarah
carter has been with the truckers and
their convoy all week in ottawa and you
know it looks like a block party every
night and i'm glad they didn't get too
mad that i said i was a rangers and
islanders fan yesterday
i don't think they were mad at all sean
it it does kind of feel like a block
party i mean people here really are
trying to show support for one another
we've got a lot of people just regular
citizens showing up trying to show their
support for the truckers and it's been
very peaceful everybody's been really
kind i've got several truckers here with
me right now i've got tyler armstrong
he's here with me you've been here from
the beginning right tyler yep i've been
here since day one yeah what is it what
has it been like for the last two weeks
for you uh it's been pretty surreal just
the amount of uh support we're getting
from the public
cash donations food donations getting
little cards from kids and everything
tears my eyes every single day it's a
very beautiful thing yeah it's been
pretty incredibly incredible how i've
been treated as well and i wanted to
talk to you really quick uh mike mike
johnson sean he's also a trucker he's
been here from the beginning what's it
been like for you when you hear prime
minister trudeau you know make
statements that uh you know that
the basically the truckers are racist or
or that they're misogynistic or that
there's criminality occurring what have
you seen and what is your response to
him on that
what i've seen in my response would be
uh
i mean even if you're depending the
camera around right now
you'll see every kind of looking person
you'll see there's probably 30 languages
spoken right here there's every kind of
person here we're all canadians
[Applause]
this is not like my father was black my
mom was white this is not a white uh
racist left
right movement this is a movement about
freedoms of canadians as individuals to
make their own decisions in their lives
freedom sean
that's what it's all about send our love
our prayers our solidarity keep it
peaceful and i predict they will win in
the end hang in there
thanks sarah i will sean sends his love
his peace and his solidarity with you
awesome thank you
all right our friends in canada sarah
carter live on the scene hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else